all right Jimmy grace all right okay I
think we should start kinda at beginning
I think we should start with Brookside
you started actually quite you know
relatively late it's not like you came
to Brookside as a 20 year old you came
to Brookside in your thirties do you
think that that was a help or a
hindrance when it comes to writing did
you have ideas already that you wanted
to get out in there
no um I'd done a bit of theatre but um I
couldn't write theater to save my life I
didn't know that at the time you saying
he didn't like it how did you not like
this hey I don't like theater no nine
times out of ten it's boring and a nice
8000 yeah you should have been here last
week it was great that always has to me
so but I was immature you know em I
hadn't gone to university or any
anything like that
and I think I was so lucky to be in the
right place at the right time cuz
Brookside was was done by Meiji TV on me
as he sighed they needed Merseyside
writers and my stint in the theater had
at least given me a body of work yeah it
was not good but it demonstrated stamina
and so I think I think it was that
really I I had but for 12 months I for
12 months I didn't know what I was doing
I nobody knew what they were doing on
that show it was the birth of channel 4
yeah we were all your I think the
average age on Brookside for everybody
working behind the scenes was 30 which
is incredibly young the thing I would do
then is I would follow the storyline
slavishly you know cuz people who know
things have given me this storyline and
I know nothing so I've got to follow the
storyline and without a word of a lie
took me about nine loads to realise
you've got to give of yourself to that
storyline and I just didn't know that
and it took me a while to find that that
was even yeah but that's just learning
on the job it's amazing way to learn
and given them in you know we're not
meant to call them soaps are we any more
polite I'm going to call it a say that
this is something about generating
storylines having to do it quite quickly
once you break away from the idea that
you've just got to stick to whatever
storyline you're given yes it must be
quite exhilarating you must learn a lot
by doing that quite early on I I knew I
was with my place even though miss
scripts were not good I could generate
story you know Monday and Tuesday with
the storyline meetings and we'd have
about 12 writers around the table and
they're all desperately trying to come
up with ideas because if you came up
with an idea you might get commissioned
because it was your idea you got more of
a chance of getting commissioned than
that meant money and your name on
Italian so it was all very very earnest
and serious but I knew I could generate
story him and also Brooks I had an
agenda there and it was political you
know and so we'd all be fighting to get
our angle on you know and and the tricks
I pulled you know I would use a buhdeuce
you know did the obvious one is listen I
come from here I'm a working class
that's awesome
I was all to get it was all think it's
all the way in brownie points and you
know I became pretty good at generating
story to such an extent I could generate
story from the smallest incident you
know I could I could cuz often you had
to you know yeah I had an episode the
Brookside to write and the storyline was
Tracy wins a hairdressing competition
was you know it was just free didn't so
yeah I could generate a no you you had
to explore the magnesia you had to dig
as deep as you possibly could you know
and I think I I think I could still do
that to excavate you know him because
you excavate in the story on your
excavating within yourself to bring
yourself to it you know yeah how can I
make this me you know it's a everything
I learnt I learnt there and there's a
lot I mean he works really hard on
Brookside and you got a lot of work done
yeah have you ever in your later years
kind of consciously recycled the
Brookside storyline M be honest Probert
in
yes and no in 1989 when I packed in
Brookside and I realized that the
television writers especially but all
writers they dream of reaching a point
where they can write what they most want
to write well they will write only what
they want to write but when you reach
that point you realize that to get there
you've already written it it's just and
also often Brookside was everything
everything that mattered to me trade at
the time I was a trade unionist and
social I'm not now I'm I'm a kind of
half-hour socialist and half art trade
unionist em but I was well into
Catholicism you know so all those things
were in Brookside and so I would just I
just threw myself into it you know but
but those themes have repeated
themselves constantly but I think we all
write about the same thing we just we
just disguise it well you tend to write
about the working-class you don't write
you do you have done and you do write
about the middle class but it's mostly
working-class yes and do you want to
explain why you choose yeah yeah yeah I
just think if you don't you're missing a
trick em that you know in a soap opera
especially you can make you can decide
the most extraordinary things that in
real life would have enormous financial
consequences but in a soap opera they
never discussed the financial
consequences it's always the emotional
isn't it you know but in real life you
just wouldn't do that you know em and
like it often in a drama somebody will
take off a ring and throw it and throw
it away or what you know you'll never
see that you'd sell it you just what it
is it's just things like that so that's
just an added dimension the the enormous
financial beard and becomes an added
dimension and I want to move on to we've
grouped kind of three dramas together
and one of them was a very particular
drama that you wanted to mention called
needle do you want to tell people about
this because not so many people know
this this yeah yeah I've got a packed in
Brookside and it was about 1989 I
imagine the phone would ring I imagine
that I'd get phone calls from people you
know and you want to write this well
nobody rang me at all you know and I was
just a so popular writer and then I got
one phone call from George Faber if all
the people will know George Weber to be
like a wonderful executive producer at
the BBC did screenplay he wanted the
writer to write about the needle
exchange scheme which was strong on me
as he said this is my big break the
phone had rung and an honest-to-god I
did loads of research on it and I just
threw myself into it if I make a mess of
this you know it's a Emmerdale far you
know I could go back to Brookside so am
I remember I remember every decision I
made every decision I made we want to
impress people this is my disk disk this
is going to get done and four years
later it'll be my calling card I've got
to impress you know I've got to show
them that hey I'm better than the
average writer I'll do things that the
average writer will not do and what
didn't where did the needle lead you
with your storytelling because one of
the things that happens in needle is
essentially one of the things I very
much enjoyed about that film is that
it's not morally ambiguous but it shows
all the sizes and it shows the size of
people who are upset about about the
drug users and the people who are trying
to stick to a very moral approach which
is to let them have needles and then the
pressure on the politician makes a
change a moment one of the things that I
found very interesting about that is
that you are known as a moral writer
yeah generally but that's quite it's
quite ambiguous and needle isn't it yes
it's probably more ambiguous because
it's better than a lot of stuff of
written you know in you just got to give
the devil the best tunes haven't you you
know and so you you you you give the
opposing arguments the what the ones
about which you're suspicious much more
much more strength and depth you know
and well I could see both sides you've
basically indicated that you do a lot of
research for your for your work and
there's normally a deadline yeah how
does that work how much how much
research how
do you push that deadline I know that's
that's the thing isn't it we I'm sure
we've all been there yeah the research
is so enjoyable isn't it but you've got
to start you got you just got to do town
yeah I hate writing page one you know
it's just a in there when I was writing
cracker we do in each story was a three
parter it would be roughly hundred and
fifty pages long so you'd finish one you
know a three parter yeah and you'd be
knackered you know because you put a lot
into cracker a lot of Mimas in crack at
a lot of stuff I knew was in cracker you
know so you'd put a lot into it and
you'd finish it and then you'd write a
story number to page one you know and
your hundred and another hundred and
fifty pages to go you know it was just
so so destroying you know really and
it's not like writing a novel you know
you they want you know you've got to do
you know but that's maybe the best way
of always you never would yeah probably
um should we talk a little bit about um
Hillsborough there's obviously an
incredibly important film and in a
really difficult film because it's a
real story it's not fictionalized and
when you you've talked about it before
obviously and one of the things that
you've said is the story in those
situations belongs to the victims and
runs to the families and but obviously
from hills where there's lots of
different size and how do you ensure
that they're that you're representing it
in the right way because even within the
families there were arguments when they
very different yes right with the thing
like hills but it was easier in that the
press had been appalling you know you
know the Sun the Sun from page the truth
if the fans pissed on the dead that's
what the Sun said if they pissed on the
dead they robbed they robbed from the
dead and they battered coppers who were
bravely trying to resuscitate the dying
that's what the Sun from Page said and
other outlets picked that story up as
well you know so so um part of it part
of the drive was to correct that
imbalance
you know ma4 it happened in 1989 and I
can't in 1996 and for the intervening
years
can I just ask you ladies ask how did
you come to it had I also do it I wrote
an episode a Krakus about a lad called
Albie who simply went around killing
journalists on the Sun and politically
or he also he also he also had this same
he was a socialist you must even a
socialist and there but is I put it he
worked in a factory
he's a working-class man who worked in a
factory but he was in Eva's and
intelligent socialist as well so he was
a contradiction and a but that's at a
certain point in the film he decides to
act the way people expect him to act so
he shaves his head and the first the
first victim is a Pakistani news agent
because that's what's expected of him no
and then he went after coppers and and
journalist on the Sun and things like
that and it was everything I felt you
know if I know I'm going to offend a lot
of people here but from a from the time
I was working on Brookside I was on easy
street and all I saw was my brothers and
sisters and families and friends
devastated no factory closure after
factory closed after factory closure and
the deep there was this massive attack
upon the British working class but it
was it was especially especially violent
against the white working-class male the
intellectual left saw them as fascists
and bigots
and the intellectual right just attacked
them anyway you know yeah and I saw this
happening you know a dedicat and part of
the Billiton tendency oh how the
intellectual left despised that man you
know a bolshie bolshie outspoken scouser
with a shiny face you know it football
fans oh how the internal intellectual
left despised them fascists and bigots
and racists and homophobes all of them
this is this is a
trade unionists oh oh for God's sake
wake up get up to the times you fighting
a lost cause those days are gone get
over it you know all those waiting class
institutions being smashed I've called
you being robbed from us you know I saw
all that going on or grief the miners
strike that
you know the coppers with bulging pay
packets 65% pay rise from mrs. Thatcher
first things she did gave the gay gave
our police officers a 65% pay rise and
all grieve and things like that was the
direct result you know they were they
smashed the trade union movement then
the strongest union in our country was
smashed by overpaid coppers overzealous
coppers you know and so I saw all this
and I was not surprised that a 89 came
and hillsgra happened you know get in
there get in there you scouts bastard
get in there you know if you go
you'd be mess at railway stations and
battered did hit you over the head get
against that wall
you know scouts bastard under this this
went on and on and on and so when I
wasn't at all surprised Hammond in 89
and I just exploded you know and I I
just made a vow that him in future it I
would see I would see at my allies on
the left but waiting class people would
be my natural allies yeah you know and I
just I just I just stopped trusting the
intellectual left and anyway I think I
think cracka a I wrote the hillsborough
drama book that that episode the cracker
came out of all that yeah you know a
white working-class male sick of
everything yeah main course come for so
yes yeah so and he was a scouser no and
so now led you to Hillsborough which was
yeah that well then the hills for the
families found out what was going on and
they came and we we met them all and we
had the big screening for them and they
took again the left we're finding
reasons to object why are you doing this
they thought I was doing it for the
money you know I mean it's just you know
that was the last thing I had to give
him the bloody money away you know and
but the families themselves those who'd
been there
no David they were well into it yes
especially when you killed her son
journalist yes it was just an amazing
but then there was a bond formed yeah
and then I went out for a walk I went
out for a walk and have a beautiful
summer's day and I came back and on my
doorstep was a darling Jones and here
Jenny Hicks a dog Dorina lost her boy
there and Jenny had lost two daughters
at Hillsboro
yeah and I'll never remember I'll never
forget the simplicity you know I walked
up to them and he said Jimmy we've come
to ask you to tell our story that was it
yeah one of the key things about
Hillsboro is actually something that
comes up a lot in your in your work
which is the difference between law and
justice yes that's what the whole film
in the end the second half of the film
is about really isn't it actually it's a
theme that runs right the way through
your words the Lord doesn't work in the
way that you think it's going to I know
until you're caught up in something you
know not many people in this country
realize that law and justice are totally
different things
that an law can be incompatible with
justice and law is designed to keep you
away from justice no and you don't find
that out until you're embroiled in it a
common which is a film a TV drama that
came out last year she also concerns the
law when you when you wrote common but
you're obviously addressing this issue
in particular but the law is not only
you know not only always without justice
it's also quite complicated isn't it so
there are elements within your when
you're writing that you have to simplify
don't you you don't it isn't exactly yes
as it would be oh I know all the time
but better it's far better for lawyers
to say oh you got that wrong mcgovern
than for a viewer to say I don't
understand any of this you know yeah
yeah you have to you have to keep it
simple yeah well you just have to keep
the drama moving in the story moving and
and M when you talk this it's really
obvious the stuff that makes you
passionate the stuff that you want to
write about it's injustice it's yes
completely you know clear yeah there is
a lot of injustice in the world do you
not ever get completely battered down by
it by the by the fact that these things
happen that you don't compel to write
about them it's oh yeah it's quite a
dark path sometimes Carmen came about
because I opened up a letter from a
woman who had a loved one inside and it
wasn't that there was a mirror
there was a mirror and this boy was
nowhere on the scene but he had to
confess the GBH or face trial for life
for murder so he confessed to GBH and
got 10 years you know rather than do
life I opened up this letter um and
exactly as you said
I said now I've had enough I've had
enough of this I'm not going to get
involved in this you know so I was just
about to write back and say I thank you
very much but I'm I'm too I'm too busy
stroke old
stroke tired stroke you know it you know
and then I looked at the date on the
letter and it was a month old the letter
was a month old
so today in the envelope over and she
sent you use the wrong postcode and so I
said to myself I can't let this woman
think I sat on this letter for a month
while still here boys inside for though
him and so I phoned up intending to say
I haven't sat on this letter you posted
to the wrong address and but as soon as
you get the human voice on the end of
the line that's it you're hooked you
know so that's the reason I was I would
say into common I didn't mean to do it
I'm slightly confident I want to kind of
move on from those three kind of radio
dramas
yeah to the street and accused what we
got on the street particularly was a wee
troll for writers and we troll for
stories we didn't entertain the notion
of the writer you know our point was
there are so many writers but there are
very few stories you know
and so we trolled we troll for stories
and we got them in and we picked the
ones that I could write if the writer
failed I know so um it was great as a
great luxury and often the writer did
fail
you know and I would rewrite every
single word but particularly in the fair
sale I think in all of them on on the
street the writer got sole credit even
if he was totally even if even if every
word has changed you know but that
notion of sitting back and thinking yeah
I could write that but then
commissioning a writer there was a there
was a writer that we
we hire the writer who was a drug dealer
and and he hadn't written a word
he'd never written a word in his life
but he had this story and I thought well
if you write about drugs or this this
person who doesn't know anything about
drugs write about drugs
yours will be more immediate and so we
commissioned him and how did and how did
you find because you do that a lot you
work with other writers yeah and
obviously that's going to involve some
some fourth hand-holding or yes
rewriting the whole thing yes how do you
find that you enjoy it would you find it
frustrating or you know yeah I
absolutely love it yeah I absolutely
love it it it's the fact that you
haven't got the right page wrong
yourself no you've got that's rubbish so
again yeah well yep well exactly you
just you you aren't writing once you've
got a 60 page script in you are no
longer writing you are rewriting and
it's a massive difference there you know
when it's good but you'll know it's
personal you'll know the writer is
writing it from somewhere in here you
know alcoholism you know we had to store
like that on the street that was deeply
personal to that writer you know him and
the energy level will be sky-high you
know him there won't be any [ __ ]
there won't be any tired regurgitation
of cliches because often the writers
were brand new and they couldn't
identify what was a cliche and what
wasn't
you know so so all that was going on as
well and it was it was a dream it was a
beautiful process you know and apart
from one writer he'll be sacked because
he was an arrogant bastard
I think every other writer every nicer
you did the street and the kids would
say it was a good process you know and
we treated them fairly with you know we
give entitled and we paid in full whack
you know don't get me wrong we've we
failed often you know him but at its
best we had simplicity of narrative and
complexity of character and I think
that's a wonderful mantra for a TV drama
I you know you what you do not want is
simplicity of character and complexity
of narrative that's ridiculous you know
it gets all quiet so we is what we had
because characters are complex you know
him there was that and the other one was
him at the end of it all at the
the story reign supreme leave your ego
at the door
and they got battered the writers got
battered I had them in tears sometimes
you know they really got a hard time
because all that mattered was the story
nothing else not your ego not your
training not your ambitions
this story is all I care about you know
em but when we got it really truly right
we that we'd end up with something
approaching a final draft that was
bloody good you know and then I we
wouldn't leave it at that we'd have
another go and any trace of the writer
was taken out any sign of effort you
explained more effort to disguise that
effort you know you did it's as if at
it's very best
it was as if we found the story in the
street you know the seeming absence of
the writer the simplicity of the
storytelling you know surely we found
this story industries you know and it
hours and hours of way to even get to
even get to the seeming absence of the
writer and the lack of effort takes even
more effort than you've ever envisaged
you know it really does deal it's funny
isn't it cuz there III always you know
in the 80s I'd sit and watch TV you see
Alan Bleasdale and you know you'd have
all these wonderful actors and you know
you go you don't know how lucky you are
look at Brookside the pieces of world
I'm working with you
and then and then suddenly and then but
then you realize that you know the
script gets the Directorate Isaiah the
director gets the Rice's the script and
he deserve you know and so she deserve
you know and so on you know how in your
illustrious career how do you think
you've changed as a writer or oh that's
a good one that I think you got this
analogy you you start off life and
you've got this creative angel on your
right shoulder you know
and this emaciated a critical devil you
know and and you think you don't know
anything but you got any gene enthusiasm
and you're right you know and your
connective angel telling you it's
marvelous and the critical devil can't
get away then but but as you I think as
you get more and more experience the
critical devil and the creative angel
sorts of equal to each other and I think
that's pretty good then you know you're
doing good work then but I actually get
a little bit more yes you aged a little
bit more the bloody critical devil is
you know hence hence the paralysis of
page one you know yeah I can't you know
I know how to start this drama but it
[ __ ] this this critical devil is telling
me it [ __ ] so I can't get started I know
I know more than I've ever known about
writing yeah and I think when I do it
it's better I think some of the stuff I
did on the street and banished even
someone solar stuff I did on banished
was better than a lot of the stuff I'd
written prior to that yeah yeah but my
god it's harder you know I found it much
harder yeah
it doesn't come easy and that's another
thing I tell myself if I'd when I was
cheering it out you know and people
picking up afters on my way you know it
if I'd known then how hard it was either
charge them a hell of a lot shock it was
no I only know now how hard it is and
you just quickly mention banished which
after so I got completely addicted to
and watched them all in one go that one
seemed I mean to write was that you've
just said it was very difficult to watch
it was much more of a kind of romped yes
yes was it yeah but I wrote that in a
totally different way i rose nearly four
episodes before we got the green light
because i was write this as a 19th
century novel you know him and I really
enjoyed the writing of it I I really did
and then there was some good stuff in
there but I think I think we I think we
went wrong well we went wrong as we got
bbc2 which is you know oh how dare we
have that scouser on our channel you
know get it off you know this isn't Wolf
Hall look that was the attitude a but
really early on really early on this
convict woman says to this guard it you
want a shag or a wank yeah that was
really early on and he and there was a
critic there was a critic who said you
could and I know exactly where that came
from a groupie drama because this
convict woman from the East End of
London uses words like shagging wank you
know so this grew be drum so there was a
lot of that going on but it was it was
undeniably flawed as well I'm not going
to hide from that it was undeniably flaw
but it's old it was really well written
yeah thank you so much firstly for the
talk it's wonderful um but I was
wondering um the story room you
described for accused in the street
sounds very similar to the American
writers room style and I don't know
anything about I hope to but I don't yet
know anything about writing in England
but it seems that people tend to write
alone and I was wondering given the
dearth of script editors as you're
saying is there a place for creating
that kind of culture of writers rooms
here and what would be needed if you
think it is a positive thing and I'm so
glad you asked that question because it
comes up every so often you know they do
BBC they are so far behind the times but
but every now and again they talk about
the writers room we shall have to
emulate the American writers room the
cost of the American writers room is
prohibitive you know think those guys
get paid an absolute bloody fortune i
subsidized the BBC on the street and
accused I was taking scripts that a dad
just we're not working the scripts we're
not working and because of the
commitments with entered into with that
writer I would rewrite the entire script
and get paid nothing get paid absolutely
nothing you know I was subsidizing the
BBC because I cared so much about the
program you know but if it ever if it I
mean I I would love it I would love it
out we could produce something really
special if they would fund a writers
room properly you know and I have a
group of four writers for a five we
don't want too many four or five writers
a did a guy or a woman in charge and and
Mac route every story beat every story
be we get all week after week after week
every single story bit and only then
send the writer the way to write it you
know you've got four or five six
experienced people wonderfully
experienced and storytelling mapping out
every single story beat and then you're
sending an experienced writer away to do
even better to bring something else to
it to bring a passion and a vitality to
the writing it couldn't fail but the BBC
will never fund it they will never fund
it they haven't got to haven't got a
clue about that kind of thing they rely
on people like me to subsidize them you
know I was knackered
I was knackered so it wasn't really a
writers room it wasn't really a writers
room it was I don't know what I was I
was like a backstop and unpaid back
stock we haven't helped you say very
much about cracker which always said to
me to be a really transformational piece
of television and I think I watched all
of it but I always knew when I was
watching an episode that you didn't
write all of it for example has gone on
to great things yeah
don't write crack as well as you did is
it really true that when you met Robbie
Coltrane you said I'd imagine them being
thin
uh-uh shocking yet it was a god I know
there are loads of writers in this room
so you'll identify with this good Neil
the kind of producer you dream about he
saw something in me that nobody else had
seen and he wanted me to write this
drama series called cracker about a
psychologist I had Satan Satan actors in
mind out I was a huge fan of John
Cassavetes both as a writer and
filmmaker and an actor you know I really
loved him and if he had that kind of
energy I admire you know never ever
stopping you know and goob says to me
what kind of what kind of character is
it what what you see him as and I said
you know a thin wiry guy loads of energy
you know he says Coltrane but I trusted
God because he'd seen something in me so
I'm I thought he must be coming from
somewhere you know so we traveled off to
Scotland to Glasgow we go to Ravi of
course Robbie doesn't come to us we've
got to go to Scotland to see Robbie at
his house on the shores of Loch Lomond
or somewhere you know so it's about half
past 10:00 in the morning and I'm like
that Oh God you know I don't fancy this
at all sound encouraged this man um you
know to take this part well why are we
doing this why do we need them why can't
we just cast an actor who's right why
have you got to get a big star or you
know usual usual things that are right
it does but basically I find that I'm
always find it difficult to talk to
actors it's particularly big named
actors you know and and so a fatal flaw
like I had a drink I had a whiskey and
then that set me down a bit so he had
another one anyway got off the train and
I was legless and this is about this is
about half 11:00 in the morning but by
the time we got up there and we go to
meet Robbie and I just you know I just I
just planted everything else as I saw
him as a thin man Robbie I saw him as a
tiny wee thin man look you're a big fat
bastard
what he'd see he'd seen this is I think
he'd seen the fair script and it's seen
what was going on and I think he wanted
it you know I think he wanted it sorry
he tolerated me I think huh huh but it
was it was nervousness really I think
that's why so many writers fond of a
drink
no they was solitary people and yet we
have to go out and meet people and we
don't like it you know I mean we this
just calm down
yeah that's what I say thank you so much
that's the real beauty of film as as
collaboration where these very fine
actors have observed from their
perspective what is wrong with your
script and and they give them
suggestions as to how to improve and
that's always the way with our writing I
think we are never satisfied with the
first root idea of a gentle you know
we'll try to do it we can never do it
always feels lacking if there isn't
somebody being murdered or some kind of
dreadful extra element
you